[Music]
kids sometimes do the weirdest things
but it's okay because you did all these
two from putting ring chips on your
fingers and mixing all types of sodas
together to drawing that s thing in
school today we're showing you that
you're not that weird after all don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos
today we're discussing 10 weird things
all kids do chip fingers there are two
types of people out there those who eat
ring shaped chips normally and those who
put them on all of their fingers and
then eat them most of us have a certain
way of eating certain foods like ice
cream Oreos and ring shaped chips this
is something even some adults can't
resist doing in private have you ever
eaten one of those ring chips by putting
them on your fingers and eating them off
it's hilarious because it takes you much
longer to eat the chips but there's just
something about putting them on your
finger that's totally irresistible this
is one of the most popular methods of
eating chips when it comes to kids if
you're still one of those people we
recommend doing this with cheeto onion
rings but it basically works with any
ring shaped chips there is no greater
satisfaction than putting that chip on
your finger and then somehow managing to
eat it there's a reason they're in a
shape of a ring in the first place right
this is something all kids do and we bet
most end up biting their fingers too so
don't worry if you think you're the
weird one on this you're definitely not
alone some kids don't even stop with
chips any ring shaped food eventually
ends up on their fingers
mixing sodas you're definitely not alone
on our next one have you ever noticed
that soda tastes much better if you mix
it with something else whether it's coke
sprite or anything else
mixing sodas is something most adults
don't ever think of doing but for kids
creating new tastes is completely normal
have you ever been to Subway and mix
every single soda in their soda machine
in a single cup you might be surprised
because people have managed to come up
with some pretty incredible flavors a
reddit user claims this drink isn't
discovered in the USA it's called spazzy
and it's coke mixed with orange Fanta or
Sunkist another user swears on lemonade
and sprite if you like cherry you'd love
Chirico
zero mixed with cherry sprite zero these
combinations would have never happened
if it wasn't for child's curiosity so
don't worry if you mix all your sodas
because you can actually end up with
some pretty awesome flavors older people
are raising eyebrows over the mixing
sodas trends and consider it rude
especially if it's done in restaurants
and other public places but this is a
very popular thing with young people
including children we're definitely
going to try mixing coca-cola with
sprite next time making gak and slime
you might not know what gas is if you're
a younger generation but nineties kids
can tell you that slime existed in their
childhood and it was called gap all kids
seem to be crazily obsessed with slimy
things and we're not really sure why
there's just something about touching it
that's just so exciting you can't really
resist it did you know it takes roughly
two minutes to make gak it's made with
glue water a mild powdered laundry soap
and just a little bit of borax borax is
an intense ingredient so gak was
reinvented as slime and it can be made
using just a few completely harm free
ingredients you can use washable PVA
glue liquid starch water and food
coloring kids love to play with these
and they especially love making
glow-in-the-dark types ever wanted to
know how the glow-in-the-dark is made
just replace regular food coloring with
neon food coloring and keep other
ingredients even though slime is super
weird
and it doesn't make sense to many adults
it's also very cool and we can
definitely see why kids love it check
out this fluffy looking slime there's
just something very pleasing about these
things isn't it who would have thought
that goo can be so entertaining the
floor is lava if you're up to date with
the 2017 social media viral trends you
know that this popular game is coming
back but it all actually started in our
childhood we're not even sure why but
all kids play the universal game of the
floor is lava it's a game that's
familiar to absolutely everyone the
concept of the game is pretty
self-explanatory the floor is lava and
if you step on the floor you lose sounds
ridiculous right
it seems like this kids game is becoming
trendy again and friends are shouting
the floor is lava
the most random places and trying to
find the nearest object they can step on
to avoid the floor it's weird when kids
do it but this game is even weirder when
adults do it did you know that variation
of the game actually originated from a
raw dolls book though wish a child
imagined his carpet was full of snakes
and hot coal then in 2002 a webcomic
uploaded a comic with a man standing on
the table with a caption the floor is
lava the game even showed up in the
Simpsons in 2004 but if you were born
before this date you know that
absolutely everyone played this game but
where did the idea of the lava come from
drawing the s thing here's another
throwback for you that was probably done
by everyone at your school including
yourself do you remember that s thing
everyone used to draw in their notebooks
it's one of the most addictive things to
draw using parallel lines and connecting
dots but it's a strange symbol that
seemed to unify every student it's an
internationally-known doodle but not
many actually know the origin behind it
there seems to be no origin behind this
weird school phenomenon a journalist
called Julian Morgan's wanted to come to
the bottom of this s thing but it has
proven to be a much harder task than he
is expected no one knows where this
thing came from and apparently it's not
even connected to the Superman symbol as
many seem to think some say it belongs
to Stussy a Californian streetwear brand
but the company denied it the mystery
behind the S thing is unknown but we bet
you still know how to draw this do you
think today's kids are still making S
shaped doodles in their notebooks if you
think you know where this enchanting as
shape came from or if it looks familiar
leave us a comment below and let's
discuss we're definitely ready to get to
the bottom of this mystery
licking grocery carts this next weird
thing is every germophobes worst
nightmare but a joy to any toddler
parents constantly complain about their
children licking or booting grocery
carts in their mouth and there's nothing
you can do to stop them we're sure
you've heard of report seeing just how
many germs there are on a grocery cart
tons of people touched the cart in a
single day and
your child decides to put their tongue
on the handle but don't worry it's not
just your child this is one of those
weird things all kids do and there's no
actual explanation behind it many
parents are also totally fine with it
exposing your children to more germs
could help strengthen their immune
system in the long run although we can't
help but cringe when we see a child
putting their tongue on the surface of
the grocery cart there is actually an
eyebrow raising solution for that and
some people think that's taking it a bit
too far check out these awesome looking
covers that you can put over the grocery
cart and make shopping a comfortable and
germ-free experience for your child
what's your opinion on this grocery cart
handle phenomenon are that much bacteria
really harmful to children or is it just
one of those weird things all kids do
and then grow out of undressing your
dolls if you owned a couple of dolls as
a child there's a good chance you've
probably done this every doll comes with
clothes but most of them end up without
them at some point kids are curious and
playing with and undressing their dolls
is something every child does although
we're short toys like Barbie dolls
weren't made for that purpose we bet
you've undressed your Barbie and Ken to
see what they have underneath their
clothes but that's not the only weird
thing kids do with dolls a very common
thing kids do is chew on the leg or the
hand of the Barbie doll whenever they're
bored or even cut off all their hair to
see what they look like balls and let's
not even mention putting the dolls in a
very compromising position with Ken kids
do tons of weird things to their Barbie
dolls but undressing them is one of the
most common things everyone seemed to do
at some point we bet that there are a
couple of Barbie dolls in your attics
that are lacking clothes right now if
you thought this was a weird thing to do
you can now forgive yourself for being
an odd kid it's completely normal and
done by practically all kids
fortune-telling with chatterboxes these
days many adults would never believe in
a fortune teller or someone who can
predict their future just by looking at
their birth date but as kids we actually
did this all the time do you remember
chatterboxes no it's not kids that talk
too much these foldable things were made
out of simply just paper what you do is
write a couple of answers on the inside
of the chatterbox and some words on the
outside and get one of your friends to
ask you question
about their future for example if they
were asking about how many kids they
will have you'd put a bunch of different
numbers in the Chatterbox but first they
have to point to a word written on the
outside and let you spell it while
opening and closing the chatterbox the
answer lies in the very last letter of
your spelled word it's one of the
weirdest games ever but if you're a
child you've probably believed in this
fortune-telling later on chatterbox is
turned into magic 8-balls and other
fortune-telling toys but this popular
game was one of the first interactive
fortune-telling experiences you'd have
as a kid you probably don't remember
anything anymore but if you do make sure
you tell us if any of your chatterbox
fortunes came true eating the cake mix
kids are true rebels and you really
can't blame them they're the ones that
get told what they can't do every single
day don't lick the shopping cart don't
do this don't do that and most
importantly don't eat uncooked things
one of the most tempting things all kids
do is probably eating the cake batter
mix even though they are constantly told
it's terrible for their stomach admit it
this is something you did too and how
could you not cake batter is too
delicious to resist but do you know why
eating cake batter is actually bad it
seems completely innocent but eating the
cake mix can actually cost a Manilla
raw flour can easily make you sick
because it comes from open fields that
grow tons of bacteria this is precisely
why we wash fruit and vegetables before
we eat them and since we can't do the
same with flour we have to cook it even
FDA encourages children not to eat raw
dough but you have to admit that this is
something you did at least once how many
of you have snuck into the kitchen to
swipe a little bit of cake batter while
your parents are baking we're telling
you kids are the real rebels on the
other hand who can resist a delicious
looking cake batter mix we also know
some parents who refuse to share the
cake mix and eat it before their kids
even noticed it was there in the first
place smelling mr. Sketch scented
markers this is for all those children
of the 90s who remember mr. Sketch
scented markers having anything scented
was ridiculously exciting but we bet
there are a few children who enjoyed the
smell of those markers so much they
wanted to see what it tastes
kids do the same with basically any
scented thing including erasers the
smell is completely irresistible
and we totally understand did you have a
favorite mr. sketch marker smell some
claim that the brown marker which is
cinnamon scented smells the best we're
sure that all kids loved the smell of
the turquoise fruit punch or the red
cherry marker recently the markers have
made its way back on the shelves and a
hilarious story behind them shows they
are made using bodily flatulence of each
freaked they're just totally
irresistible and we can definitely see
why kids would obsess over the smell of
these markers you can also easily make
these types of scented markers at home
using essential oils and old colored
pens find out new scents and even though
it smells delicious try to keep the Pens
out of your mouth enjoy it while it
lasts because once you get older
having scented markers in your office
can raise a few eyebrows from your
coworkers we bet many of us would prefer
doing weird things as a kid than normal
things as adults for more videos like
this one check out 10 genius ways you
can reuse old toys don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up see you next time
[Music]